oh sorry i'm not ready [ __ ] nerd i
know you guys like my skin
dude default boy i mean uh excuse
excuse you default human i actually
identify as an alien
do you do that the clicky thing when you
stalk people and do you like
awesome so much inside of everybody's
holes
oh hell yeah that sounds fun thank you
it is for me
yeah no it sounds fun exclusively for
you i was expecting a lot more enemies
to be here
and surprisingly i found one if you want
to make sickly there's like a whole [ __ ]
ton of uh impulses down there no i'm
okay i'm not good enough to do sick
plays
actually you know what scratch that i'm
gonna i'm gonna grab some of those
dude i'm gonna make the sickest place so
sick that you might die while making
them
no you don't know that that's the
guaranteed
okay rick thanks
morbo we gotta go to the
thing marble i don't know i've never
seen the show
[Laughter]
don't worry i'll miss every shot every
shot will miss all right this is where
the aggressive building comes in
oh i got the double d knock i am in
trouble i need a door unable to edit
this
oh god i got in trouble ah there were
two of them
i've got
[Laughter]
don't go back there you can do this
he has no idea there you go
the last shot died dude i'm real proud
of you but it seems like our team might
lose this one
i'd like to think that if i made my pro
move a little bit better it would have
worked out for us but
alas i'm terrible the blue is coming i'm
going to die to the blue
it's going to happen what is your
favorite thing to do
there you go
you can do it john wick no john works a
real oh that
nope maybe just it's todd wicks please
john
[Laughter]
john wicks please touch him okay thank
you
give me that oh give me that no no no i
want to live
i want to live set a sweet trap
set a trap do it bro move i did it
oh no i didn't have any no i clicked why
didn't you please
all right well i feel like that one's on
me i feel like we should have won this
one
i feel like yeah that was [ __ ] down
too yeah that was entirely your fault
maybe standing in the open wasn't the
play damn it maybe me
trying to sneak up on two people with a
shotgun from 100 meters away
wasn't the best idea
uh you know it happens yeah
for some reason it only happens to me i
don't know maybe maybe
maybe i'm stupid maybe i'm the bad one
no that can't be it it's impossible oh
no no no no
why aren't we on the bus five seconds
man calm your boobs come on
hurry up what is this pub g let's go
your boobs are so uncalm right now
this is going to be funky tilted circle
[Music]
oh hello i see that i'm going to crawl
up in here behind you if you want to
swirl back for me
all right like literally build a ramp up
right here oh i see i'm dying
yeah dude check out all of my monies i
swear
spend them on that sweet sweet stuff i
definitely need
oh dear ah i didn't see him i heard the
whoosh
he can't hit me if i'm dead no
i think he got me man i'm gonna go out
on my own terms bye world
[Laughter]
well that was fun was it really we
didn't win
it can't be fun
oh boy i kind of want to head retail and
then move in
okay easy enough for me i was because i
was about ready to go to tilted i'm like
well it's gonna be a short round for me
but thanks for
saving me from myself they just got
revived
sorry i threaded a really cool needle it
was awesome it was so sick and legit
i literally had a guy break down my ramp
and rebuild the ramp to a
to a chest and take the chest from me
just now
well maybe you should get better and
stop letting people
yeet on you that's not the right word
yeah you know you know when you get
yeted on
when you got that eat when someone yeets
all over you oh wow our team's already
up how did that even happen hacks no
i don't think that's a valid reason you
can't just blame everything on hacks man
[Laughter]
can't argue with that flawless logic
according to
tyler oh 10 down plus
our team how do they won they got it
good
they got good and won that that
shoot yep tyler yeah
i got three hours of sleep last night
i'm pretty tired
all right i'm pretty tired
oh no no no no
no mine god damn it [ __ ] you
it's me i know [ __ ] you i was still
there that doesn't mean
that doesn't mean it's okay oh don't
worry i'm stealing your chest
we're friends that makes it worse knock
them
oh crash god [ __ ] damn it
every time god damn this game
anyway i'm not there anymore i'll let
you know when i when and if i get this
crossbow kill
because i know you're dying to hear
about that and i'm gonna i'm gonna make
a faithful recreation of whatever the
hell is going on in your game
you're just drawing no i've got
you oh i'm dead already oh man but i
don't even get to make my i was gonna
make an artistic recreation of you
dude you don't even know what i was
making it was gonna be so good
look ah [ __ ] oh it's you
i like how you're just telling me i
can't see you no no no no it's good it's
good it's you
you've got a sweet scar coming out of
this
bush here and and there's like hey
we need a fortnight background oh wait
hang on i got this okay so
you're here and there's people
everywhere swooping in on you all swoop
deep style
stop right there criminals come and
you're like
bang bang bang bang bang boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom
and then got him and then
all of you with your gun gotta run gotta
run gotta run gotta run gonna run
and then this guy comes up behind you
whoops uh oh hang on
this guy comes up he's like stop right
there where do you
where do you think you're going and then
all of a sudden pew
pew pew uh
the poink there goes your
boosh and now you're dead oops no no
you're dead wait
there we go all right that was my
faithful recreation of whatever the hell
you were just doing
oh god damn it of course i go on the
side that doesn't have an entrance
oh no no no no but i wanted this
somebody land next to you no they i
didn't land on the roof of this place
and they did so
white the [ __ ] what the oh [ __ ] you
they freaking are you [ __ ] kidding me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
i've never had more anger in my veins
all right
whatever let's just get this i have no
ammo because i wasted it i'll shoot
that guy oh hit you
didn't knock you though don't know how i
didn't knock you come on
give me those sweet sweet knocks come on
give me the knocks
yes finally got a knock i had a guy
right in front of me i had those
crossbow
sights in my vision that's if that's how
you say that that's that yeah that is
the way
that is the will and that is the way of
that
well that's another for me and to prove
how great i
am there you go jumps ahead
tilted oh dealt all right
i'm ready if you're ready i'm ready
i'm near you
nice you're near me hell yeah
that is what friends are that's what i
need that's what a lot of people tell me
sadly there's only so much me to go
around i found
a ammo box where a toilet should be
yeah that seems about right i always
like to make sure i've got my bullets
near where i [ __ ]
it's my most vulnerable moment so
they're probably all in loot lake
they're probably all in
your mop
that's that's not very nice
that's not nice got them are they
are they are are they my soon-to-be
siblings
you said they're in my mom
[Laughter]
no they're not you know what you got me
you reversed the god
i thought i had you turns out i was
mistaken you really switched that burn
around
someone sticked my saturated yeah missed
me
missed me missed yes no no no no no
dude i'm nailing you i'm nailing it
every shot no misses dude i'm so good at
this game
yeah ethan is coming to pick up a couch
that is
tj's to make it his couch so it's his
he made it sound like he was gonna cast
a spell
he's gonna place the bonds of ownership
all over he's gonna make sure the
sanctimony is not
breached oh i guess sweet impulse
grenade
you're about to see the sweetest action
that you've ever seen in your life
i'm eating on them never mind not eating
not eating eating is not happening
i'm stuck in
they're all up in here oh [ __ ] of course
i died i had
one shot and i was dead god damn it yeah
they came up in hard and fast just like
the way wait's mom likes it dude that's
rude man
dude that's mean why are you gonna be
like that always a weight mom joke
it's always a weight mom's there hasn't
been a weight mom joke since 2014.
we've been clean since then oh
you've ruined it you've soiled it all
right one more one more
don't miss me too much i'll be there
hopefully before you die
well i i don't plan to die this round
i've made a commitment i'm actually
gonna be good this time
all right never mind i ran straight into
a tree and couldn't go anywhere
eat okay and uh
see i'm saying it just normally like why
what's wrong with me
it's yeah it's been a recent thing i've
started doing it as a joke and then all
of a sudden he's
young and i can't stop man
there's fighting yep i see it
i'm gonna try to i'ma [ __ ] him up
or all of my shots are going to miss
yep every shot i need that crossbow kill
knock down no my arrow was going to hit
him i'm sorry
oh no i didn't know you were hitting
that guy
all right i'm reviving you don't worry
buddy
get out of my way hey
oh my god i've got three
no you're dead again i'm dead again
what the [ __ ] all the explosions just
destroyed me
i'm gonna die aren't i i'm gonna die
aren't i i'm gonna die
oh yeah here i go oh oh oh
i'm out of materials oh boy they're
after me
they're after me they're they're after
me i can't
barter for save me i want to live i want
to live
i want to live i don't trust going in a
porter ford i'm just going to stay to
the side of the portal
whoa who the [ __ ] try me try me
try me cry me oh boy oh
ow god damn it why me why me
why me help please help john wick
please help help
help help me help me
god [ __ ]
teammates you [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
anyway i'm out
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so stupid this game's
stupid and all the developers are
terrible
maybe all right
goodbye and bye you too bye-bye
[Music]
you